funzionato siamo invisibili
proprio oggi testeremo il blitz
l'aifa trucchetti di among sarà super
divertente testare tutti i trucchetti ma
prima di dettare lasciate un mi piace se
così video senza i 15 mila mi piace
faremo anche una seconda parte in cui
troviamo altri trucchetti glitch errori
bug gioco consigliate seri pure voi con
me alla fine del video scrivete ci fosse
stato il vostro trucchetto preferito
siete pronti
mettetevi così prenderne primo grigio
trucchetto non so come chiamarli come li
chiamiamo bug primo trucchetto in questo
trucchetto di como riuscire a diventare
invisibili se volete provare anche voi
assicuratevi di seguire tutte le
indicazioni passo per passo perché se
saltate qualche indignazione potrebbe
non funziona comunque come dovrebbe
funzionare questo trucchetto dove
l'autore andare nella mappa che eccoci
qua dopo di che dobbiamo andare nel
computer scaricare su cast mai
dovete cliccare sul foglio rosso in cui
si è scritto b impostor diventa il posto
così diventerete imposto poi dovete
andare ok qua vicino al 20 st bottas e
sabotate o2 l'ossigeno ecco fatto adesso
togliete la mappa quando questo
countdown arriva al numero uno solo
quando arriva uno dovete entrare nel
rank quindi aspettiamo che arrivi a uno
non dovete parlarne prima del dopo solo
quando arrivavano 1
aspettiamo
ok ora a fare la scritta normalmente
l'impostore avrebbe vinto perché per il
sabotaggio critique ma invece l'abbiamo
semplicemente trento pento guardate un
po cosa per un vicino ha funzionato
siamo invisibili che venga mai
fighissimo esseri invisibili ma poiché
l'altro anche il mio petto è diventato
invisibile anche il mio cappello perché
non si vedono poi per esempio ammazzare
quell'altro dammi allora penso da quello
che ho letto se però uccidi qualcuno non
sei più invisibile quindi possiamo anche
testare questo estremo da ecco qua è
difficile entrate che sono le porti
senza vedere dove il professore con la
quale riuscivo che proviamo a ucciderlo
e vediamo se rimaniamo invisibili o no
purtroppo questo mantello
dell'invisibilità stile harry poster e
ne uscirete qualcuno scompare quindi
state attenti se lo usate comunque
bellissimo che voto date questo
trucchetto io ti do un 10 con tre
invisibile e gli do un 8 perché
purtroppo quando quando ma se qualcuno
devi ritornare di nuovo normale quindi
non sei più visite dei grandi poteri
dirigenti invisibile ma stiamo ora
questo trucchetto è come
teletrasportarsi allora andiamo
in una partita qualsiasi online ok
allora quello che dovete fare è una
volta che parte il countdown quindi che
sta per iniziare la partita
dovete muovervi potuto da un lato tutto
da un altro lato io proverò a muovermi
tutto a sinistra prima dobbiamo però
aspettare che inizi la partita inizia
dai kart anche in francese e in tedesco
ok purtroppo in quella partita non
iniziavano mai non so perché ogni tanto
fanno così a questa è piena il mese non
so perché ogni tanto non so se succede
anche voi scrivete solo ma non fanno mai
iniziare le partite
allora vediamo se questa partita inizia
che si sta iniziando che vedete il
countdown
voi continuate a muovervi continuate a
muovervi dovuto funziona
chiumenti e nel frattempo no non ha
funzionato
riproviamo
vediamo video video video xi ha
funzionato questa volta ci guardate
regione direttore invece di iniziare lì
nel tavolo un'offerta nel reattore poi
saputo ma perché hanno già fatto un
emergency meeting ma siamo soli quattro
che hanno già scoperto allora ad aprirmi
curiosa hanno già votato più in crisi e
impostano frangente il rosa l'imposta
ridisegnare lo vedevo le quali siamo
solo in 4 io ho iniziato di là quindi
hanno visto il mio hotel e fra smorto e
hanno detto un impostore quindi
scappiamo il voto ma sicuramente non in
future vabbè allora già che esistiamo
andiamo basta allora sono sicuro che
rosa tornato nuovamente ok io cosa
l'arancione note l'ho scoperto strani
giocare in tre
come abbiamo visto con questo trucchetto
come si fa il teletrasporto prossimo
trofeo questo trucchetto è per avere il
nome invisibile quindi il nome
trasparente c'è insomma non avere nessun
nome
bisogna copiare una cosa e incollarla
non basta appunto cancellare tutto
perché i nuovi altrimenti vi richiede di
mettere qualcosa oppure c'è scritto
semplicemente il nome player
sì quindi dovete incollare questo
carattere io ve lo metto qua sotto se
andate nei commenti ci sarà il primo
commento mio in cui vi metterò appunto
questo carattere da incollare io l'ho
già copiato faccio facebook e guardate
un po già si vede che qua non c'è
nessuno
ora proviamo a iniziare il gioco e
vediamo se appunto avremo realmente il
nome invisibile cioè non abbiamo fatto
bene
ecco qua non appare nessun nome o la mia
ma è stranissimo c'è non c'è nessun nome
sono semplicemente un personaggino
eccomi qua
anche qua appunto sono senza nome diamo
se cambiamo colore
se sarò se rimango appunto senza nome il
mio altro colore viola proviamo un
cappelli o ho tolto il pet per sbagliare
il suo bottino non l'ho mai comprato
ricordate nell'altro episodio se l'avete
vista abbiamo comprato assieme il minime
ho mai comprato il robottino torino non
ho regalato lo so forse un altro blitz e
cioè errore o trucchetto non siamo
neanche accorti che bello
betti in più allora che vota diamo
questo trucchetto questo ti do un sette
e mezzo perché non è molto utile 18 ei
e voi che amate gli date che possiamo
ora al prossimo progetto questo
trucchetto in pratica dice che puoi fare
entrare il tuo pet dentro ai muri il
bravissimo e con questo trucchetto
possiamo fare tre inoltre pezzi dentro
ai muri vediamo se funziona
ecco qua allora in questo caso dice non
abbiamo trovato europei
così è arrivata da niente proviamo con
il robottino e allora come funziona
bisogna andare in un muro
questo a sinistra proviamo questa
sinistra salire qua
e allora devo un po per esempio dobbiamo
lasciare il pet qua no a lui c'è la
ruota quindi sulle ruote
ok allora io non riesco a farlo entrare
nel muro ma potrebbe essere che magari è
il robottino che se come a questi
movimenti un po più lenti rispetto agli
altri pezzi magari questo blitz non
funziona con il robottino proviamo
cambiamo noi rimettiamo il minime e dire
che come cappello anche rimettiamo il
minimetro e torniamo rosa visto che oggi
io sono rose e vitale
vediamo vediamo vediamo no ragazzi
purtroppo questo non riesco a farlo
funzionare però ho visto appunto che
tante persone riescono a farlo
funzionare incastrandolo in questo vanno
avanti e praticamente il pet si
trasporta e riescono anche a farlo
scorrere proprio nella stanza però io
purtroppo non ci riesco non so perché se
voi avete provato questo trucchetto
esistete riusciti fatecelo sapere nei
commenti così magari riproviamo sostiene
stiamo era il prossimo resto trucchetto
un errore un glitch un bug del gioco in
cui se voi andate a fare il body scanner
di continuo dovreste poi avere il
cerchio addosso e potreste camminare
insomma più di cerchio addosso non so se
stacca con la scozia
ora proviamo e vediamo se funziona avete
prima andare al computer raggiungere la
tassista non lo fa usare lo scampo ok
meno male ad abitare queste quindi
toccare un bel bass summit scan ok
infatti è apparsa lì nelle tasche ora
illuminata di giallo allora cosa bisogna
fare dovete cliccare su news
dovete cliccare su utah azionarlo e poi
chiuderlo velocemente per tantissime
volte
ora proviamo vedere quanto velocemente
riusciamo a fare banca freschi o da
amici o da apri chiudi ma è lento troppo
lento sicuramente dal computer molto
molto meglio perché basta cliccare velo
dal cellulare un po lento allora finora
non è successo niente
non so se costerà questo trucchetto
vediamo se si rese evitare guasta non è
stato più bassi e vitale però secondo me
personaggino adesso sta infatti notare
come il dammi ci guarda ma per niente
ragazzi purtroppo questo non funziona
almeno da cellulare non funziona da
sicuramente da computer funziona quindi
se voi lo avete provato a scrivere solo
nei commenti di sensi un po se
funzionanti o trucchetto questo è un
trucchetto per avere più possibilità di
essere in cura
se avete scrive in tantissimi che vi
piace essere impostori la maggior
pratico e come si aumentano le
possibilità di implementare impostore ci
sono due trucchetti
uno è di rimanere completamente fermi
una volta che entrate in una partita
offre quindi proviamo questo trucchetto
vi andiamo e non tocco niente non
tocchiamo niente anche se il problema è
che se ne sono altamente fermi avete
visto forse stanno così lerda lo stesso
trucco appunto perché anche loro
vogliono stare in fornitori quindi
magari sono immobili anche loro
quindi ovviamente penso che se anche
altri personaggi rimangono completamente
fermi le nostre possibilità di
registrano vediamo ma in questo caso non
hanno spianato e cioè soprattutto dire
act star trek glik il proprio noi ci
siamo distratti perché c'erano le tasche
starter riact strano fa parte di qualche
click
abbiamo scoperto un nuovo blitz provando
un nuovo blitz aveva detto perché un
bacio dobbiamo vedere se facciamo
portiere reactor che cosa succede
e dice di far partire il reazioni tutte
le prima perché vi è mai successa sono
tutti quadro all'altro come mai ha
finalmente mi hanno trovato non eri tu
per un altro
meno trovato ancora di tik tok come tik
tok non votate dicono no per favore e
completate le tasche ok mostrano che
c'erano tutte quelle tasche come hanno
fatto a mettere solo ieri stanno andando
a tutti dietro all'altro sapete com'è il
mio petto è rimasto qua poverino forse
quando viene ucciso il pezzo urbano e lì
non so perché noi abbiamo visto già cioè
quello che si macchiano la verde ma come
fecero più di un impostore allora ok
riprendiamo il nuovamente rimango
immobile questa volta sono arancione
vediamo iniziato subito questo bene slot
c'è il rosso perché io infatti ho
cominciato iniziato
[Applauso]
ma perché sono tutti così barozzi sa se
la velocità più alta come forse questo
trucchetto congiunte uno pure funziona
solo se anche di altri non fanno tutti
immobili
il secondo trucchetto per avere più
possibilità di diventare il motore è una
volta che entri nel gioco devi cambiare
cappello in continuazione su tantissimi
misti missini cappelli devi cambiare
quindi proviamo xvi qua andiamo su
cappelli cambiamo cappello storia di
avermi cambiato abbastanza vediamo ha
funzionato in complesso guerra che bel
cappello che mimavano riproviamo io sono
ancora a recinzione
andiamo a cambiare mi raccomando dovete
cambiarne tantissimi velocissimamente
continuiamo cambiare cappelli
continuiamo continuiamo continuiamo oggi
è stato quindi è scivolato ha preso
questa partito altrimenti dovrò stare
sul tempo guai cambiare card in alcune
partite mi è capitato di vedere qualcuno
che stava facendo questa cosa qui che
stavano cambiando cappelli
costituzionali
basta lo trova mai il cappello festa
scelte di 10 8 10 siamo stati dieci non
cambia il cappello da 10 10 1 andato via
e chissà che cappello mi capiterà adesso
vai e come corre particolari funzioni no
[Musica]
è il tuo telefono che sfigato che non ti
vuole far fare l'impostore provando i
gleeks anche già vinto ammazzate tutti
erano in tre
va bene riproviamo per l'ultima volta a
cambiare caselli lei non funziona più
direi allora che questo trucchetto non
funziona
peccato era interessante questo
trucchetto per diventare su tre
impostori magari sono stata sfortunata e
non ha funzionato adesso fammi sapere
che è il trucchetto che mi è piaciuto
più di tutti nel frattempo qua stanno
votando stanno parlando in russia
farfalle trucchetto vi è piaciuto più di
tutti se volete una seconda parte
lasciate un bel mi piace ora vi lascio
parlare dell'inas puoi cliccare per
vedere
i nostri altri video di a morgan so
quello che volete cliccate su quello che
preferite
buona visione